I am nobody's [ __ ] you are mine I will
be the one suffer guys done no it's cut
my life into pieces that's where a pic
sit I know that everybody we're gonna
watch the real reason gently looks
completely different now oh boy we've
only seen the ones the only movie we've
seen gently cradle to the grave I've
seen a lot of gently film be cover the
iron mask trailer yesterday I was
talking about the trailer with somebody
then gently got brought up and something
about gently having a disease got
brought up some kind of heart disease
like hyperthyroidism or something anyway
my buddy sent me the real reason gently
looks completely different out I'm like
alright I'll just watch this side you
know and you know in the lawn coming out
and he's in it figured it's a great time
to understand why gently hasn't really
been around that much lately
[Music]
Lele Angie is one of the most well known
faces in martial arts movies but you
probably know him better as gently from
martial arts movies in the 80s and 90s
up to modern-day franchises like the
extreme rivet Li has been an action 11
for as long as and they excited about
member but Dan's were sent into a frenzy
after a 20 oh wow after appearing age
beyond his years went viral the snapshot
was oh man
unrecognizable as the great martial arts
oh I've never seen thank you three the
martial artist would have just turned 55
at the time the buzzword the picture was
posted but many thought he appeared to
be twenty or thirty years older people
made their concerns known all around the
world but is there really any reason to
worry here are the real reasons why Jet
Li looks completely different cult
master JD is an actor with a won
competitive level transitioning to a
movie career 19 since then he's appeared
in both Chinese movies and Hollywood
productions but he's done more the names
of animals guys withdrawal from the
spotlight had to do with the diagnosis
of hyperthyroidism when he announced he
was suffering from the illness
Lee said that the condition left him
feeling uncertain as to whether or not
he could continue working as an actor in
arts movies despite this setback Lee
seemed content about the situation
saying in 2013 I'm in pain but I'm not
suffering I'm happy gone viral
Lee's diagnosis again became cause for
concern in May 2018 was the sweater
taken of him at its a pet temple went
viral the photo which showed the five
foot six star hunched over with short
gray hair in glasses made him look
remarkably older than his age leaves
relative absence from American movie
screens in recent years
coupled with the implied notion that he
was gravely ill helped the image to
circulate rapidly suddenly a man who had
convincingly defended entire Nations on
the screen looked like the sort of
person you would help clear early
fortunately things aren't nearly as bad
as they might look while an overactive
thyroid can cause drastic fatass 500
convention heart rate it's a treatable
condition while the disease has [ __ ]
showmanship his lifestyle
it's reportedly never threatened his
life as his manager told The Washington
Post he has hyperthyroidism that he's
been dealing with for almost ten years
oh wow ten years and he's dealing with
it he's all well and good
a painful career Lee has a lot more
going on with his body than an
overactive thyroid lice mass wound
enough damage in plain sight for our
entertainment his whole life as a result
of his many injuries we have said he
suffers from problems in his legs and
spine with the issue is keeping him from
being able to stand up straight for too
long the damage is part of the history
in martial arts that goes back decades
earning him a torn knee that required
surgery to fix at the age of 18 and a
major back injury at the age of 23
according to the South China Morning
Post Lee has said he was told by doctors
in 2013 that he would end up in a
wheelchair if he continued to work in
martial arts films which helps to
account shows output in the genre since
then look at blaming the movies he's
already done get to live forever but Lee
himself only gets one chance from a bad
angle Lee's public relations people were
quick to pounce on the emerging viral
story with his manager telling USA Today
that his
was quote completely fine though Lee's
manager assured readers that Lee
appreciated the outpouring of concern he
also made it clear that the rulers of
Lee's declining health were greatly
exaggerated not to mention a snap
judgment based on one photo of
questionable composition fair as Lee's
manager for that it's one picture and
people are making these interpretations
but they were famously wrong angle and
the wrong time of day I could look for
Al as well yeah for the photo gained
traction with news outlets around the
world social media commentators pointed
out that much of Lee's appearance could
come down to issues of lighting posture
another external factor is not
indicative of failing health the bad
photo Theory has merit in December 2017
Lee's shared a photo on Instagram
wishing his fans a happy new year while
its appearance in the video is similar
to his look in the viral photo he
appears considerably healthy doesn't
look super duper no ha ha this is Jack
we shall happy holidays in the great
year 2018 Romeo is fine while Lee does
happy for me oh whoa I'm not here to be
because his health is declining nor are
things as bad as one photo makes it look
Lee is still working as a filmmaker that
Lee's kept most of his work aside from
the expendable series in China that may
change soon as the actor is reportedly
in talks to star in the live-action
version of doesn't mean he's done
kicking a rental rainbow thanks for
watching click the looper everybody came
to our YouTube - hey check out all this
cool stuff we know you love - wow I've
never seen that photo no me neither I
just heard that yeah is he okay decline
we gotta get to the bottom of this I
think they said a whole bunch of things
in the video but I wasn't really
listening busy being concerned about his
frail appearance in this photograph but
I got from this was now it's time to
have a follow up with him and Jackie
Chan bursting each other yeah it's
finally time for them to do an all-out
no-holds-barred action extravaganza it
better be rated R for non-stop action
sequences intense bloody violence and
actors performing their own stunts yeah
yeah it should come with one of those
jackass to school
don't try this at home who's a
professional it is a bummer to hear
about this I heard something about a
year ago when maybe around this photo
actually came out he had a condition
with and yeah hyperthyroidism where his
heart rate like at resting point that
sometimes could it's like a 130 to 140
like if it got to a certain point if he
did any actual physical demanding
exercises yeah it could literally kill
the guy yeah you know from a fan
standpoint of course as his hardening no
he should just keep making movies man he
should go out the way he always wanted
to take em BRR you know like Jackie Chan
door number the 90s he came out to the
scene like rumble in the Bronx brought
some of his films over here rush hour
came out and then eventually Jet Li came
over here his first American film was he
was the villain and Lethal Weapon 4 and
we were psyched about that and I had
seen some of his Chinese films before I
remember being younger and it was always
like jelly or Jackie Chan who do you
want they were like my Marvel and DC
growing up I remember that distinctly
because you taught me the school of
Jackie J yeah side of a Jackie Chan but
there's no doubt I I think in terms of
performer Jackie Chan in terms of
martial artists I would say gently
gently as fights just seems so intense
and fast I like I always remembered that
being the thing growing up is like
Jackie Chan de is the more slapstick and
the more using found objects and gently
is just fast and lean and me well it's
like you know Jackie Chan was for sure
as a real martial artist but he grew up
in Peking Opera so he was a really a
performer whereas jelly was a heavy
competitive martial artist as a kid was
insane I don't know a bit do this with
people now I don't think they have like
Donnie and go on a talk show don't like
Jackie can gently would go on talk shows
like chillin or whatever there would be
like could you before some martial arts
for us is we've ever seen them before
yeah I remember when gently came on I
think is for Romeo Must Die and he did a
whole bunch of moves and it was so cool
man did he beat the [ __ ] out of ya get
the crap out of line you asked for a
Leno Conan was in the audience that
night it's true what they're actually
pointing out in this video it's like I
think some people might see that photo
and just chalk it up to age
actually doing research but either way
even if it didn't have a disease and he
was just getting older his films have
made such an impact in cinema he is one
of the people who I think has helped
continue the wave or paved the way for a
lot of martial arts legendary actors oh
yeah honor date ones as well it's like
yeah if he has to retire like let him
retire it's cool that he's still doing
some work here and there but if I see
him like doing martial arts in a movie
I'm also gonna get a little concerned
yeah cuz that was the I didn't actually
know the reason but the original thing I
heard a few years back was yeah he can't
afford to get his heart rate up too high
otherwise it'll mean really bad
repercussions and so yeah he's gotta
stop basically doing a strenuous martial
arts type of stuff as much of a bummer
is that as he's in his 50s now I mean
like how much longer would you want to
be making martial arts epics I guess
partly yeah and also - yeah I like the
deconstruction they did the picture
because the more you look at it the less
frail he seemed to me in it especially
the more pictures I see if I'm now
because then I just remember how old he
is and the fact that it has been a good
long while since I saw like last time I
saw him in American movie was like
Expendables 2 and he literally like
pieces out of that movie in the first
couple of minutes well he's an
Expendables 3 John oh sorry
Tara not much though much you saw an
American every John maybe he peaced out
of that one I camera at a bull he peaced
out of both we got to the bottom I see
him working on other movies and stuff
even behind the scenes and doing a lot
of charity work
I saw one quote that said like yeah part
of why he hasn't been doing so much
movies is because he's been doing a lot
of philanthropy which if that's true
yeah you know good on the guy for that I
actually saw a quote going around
Instagram from him recently like and
fallen yeah
please follow me yeah hi new products
yes it really stuck with me it's it's
rare where I just read some quote on
social media and I and it makes me think
for a while there are people who will
see you on their free time and then
there are people who will make time to
see you we get a lot of random questions
about how to handle friendships and
social situations in our patreon the
time I read that a few weeks ago that
really stuck with me so he's a very wise
gentleman yeah you gotta make more time
for Jet Li all right guys well gently
what is your favorite gently movie
or gently fight scene you better say the
sequence when he's hopping structures in
cradle to the grave what's your favorite
frail gently photo John don't be
insensitive sorry white people as my
whiteness talking or understand not yet
I can't wait for that authentic Mulan
movie where they're all speaking English
subscribe to looper subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about the get notified whenever we got a
video up let's end this with up David
Gandy mmm-hmm the whitest man we have at
our patreon as kids you know so David I
wrote you a poem here he goes the best
poem you all have ever heard in your
entire life his name is David a man I
wish I had dated always on my radar
excellent at the guitar will look sexy
with a cigar these words are the
introduction to his memoir mr. Gandhi
come down to LA well toast with brandy
cradle my woody and I'll call you my
auntie side note mr. Gandhi toy stories
music is composed by Newman
Randy hails from the Bay Area
lick my very real oh very up as you
ceranae me with la Cucaracha keep
climbing the belting charts and the
skills of martial arts watch the blood
pressure beware of those delicious
pop-tarts and you'll forever have my
heart I hope you share this at the next
Sunday Mass where you are performing
music I hope you cradle his woody at
Sunday Mass Toy Story is my right
Chrysler wooden I'll call you my Andy
it's a great line deluxe - it's good I
was gonna get it kind of clever